- [Narrator] Most people think
this fruit smells terrible.
It's been described using words like,
rotting onions or raw sewage.
Not this guy, though.
(lively music)
If you're not that familiar with durian,
it has a spiky rind and the inside,
is a yellow, soft colored creamy fruit.
It's native to Southeast Asia and
because of its odor, is actually
banned from many public places.
Besides having a distinctive smell,
durian also has a distinctive taste.
- It's like a peanut caramel.
- [Narrator] Numb taste literally means
your mouth will go numb.
- Wow, I can feel the numbness.
- This might well be
my new favorite fruit.
- [Narrator] People in general,
are divided on this fruit.
Those who love it, love it.
- The durian is so tasty.
- It's really good.
- Tastes much better than it smells.
- [Narrator] And there are others
who just can't get past the smell.
For Durian Seng, it is the perfect fruit.